if your nerve deny you go above your  nerve Emily Dickinson  and Cheryl Strayed  I'm sorry you have to walk a thousand  miles just to finish that sentence  why don't have to walk a thousand miles  Happy Trails  long we're in my real life hanging out  here must have been some breakup huh  breakup is sort of a shorthand how much  do I love you my mother was the love of  my life  they're using heroin and you're having  sex with anyone who has  here think about quit only once every  two minutes or so they love put a bunch  of stuff quit jobs quit marriages you're  an idiot  I didn't have a choice never been a time  when it was a fork in my Road here are  some questions I've been asking myself  what if I forgive myself what if I was  sorry but if I could go back in time I  wouldn't do a single thing differently  what if all those things I did were the  things that got me here  turned away